challenge jetzt schon wieder verpackt
wie begreift wenn wir den sind nicht
meine freunde herzlich willkommen die
heute 29 nicht lassen scheiterte auf dem
kanal wieder videos rausgesucht
vorbereitet auf die wir heute reagieren
wollen ich würde sagen
direkt vorm ist sport zu machen wollte
etwas abnehmen verlängert verlängert
bitte sofort sofa bis zum kühlschrank da
habe ich haben wir ende mit dem
videospiel gebäude war eine wilde zeit
als da wo ich vorher jeden tag gefühl
dass ich mit der sache reagiert habe
aber nicht durch liegt ja getroffen
nette dame ganz liebe grüße gehen raus
sowieso ich glaube aber streicheln so
heißt sie nach so guckt wirklich sie nun
ich habe verstanden gefühlt
bratwürstchen den ohren wieder
frühstücken mit sandra sie hat wieder
halb
halbe tonne seite ja übrigens neues
t-shirt oder 2020 es wird eher limitiert
seien auf ich glaube nur 2000 stück also
seid schnell meine lieben freunde wie es
aber die url
[Musik]
so hat immer die jungs um kleider auf
eine unterirdische behausung wenn du ein
buch kennst dann weißt du wie es endet
okay hast du schon mal buch gelesen ja
welches ich war ein bisschen weg ich hab
ein bisschen hier alles china gemacht
habe mich ein paar andere dinge immer
deswegen freue ich mich natürlich auch
hier wieder zu sitzen und ein bisschen
[Gelächter]
es ist einfach ein flugzeug dunkel
draußen um zu berichten da muss man ganz
klar sagen sandra hat wieder kontakt und
leuten aus leverkusen als unseren
podcast hört wandert regelmäßig date
aber alle kommen einfach konstant aus
leverkusen und einer aus nirgendwo keine
dates
[Applaus]
so kann man bei polizei schwarzarbeit
[Musik]
erkennt mich eigentlich habe viele
briefe von ihm bekommen
[Musik]
ich kann mir den jungfernstieg in
hamburg auch nur wegen geilen kacheln
die irgendwie mal herfahren und leuten
die straße
berlin
natürlich gehört zu berlin das war
hamburg das war berlins lakers hamburg
vollidiot kuh bist du auf der werkbank
bobby bist du unsichtbaren schutz nicht
gleich an das redeforum
[Gelächter]
okay das trennt den weizen wirklich von
der spö kann man hier jetzt abbrechen
wie kommen wir abbrechen ich kann so war
nicht so dass ich mich jetzt bitte in
ruhe vernünftig in mathe laufen jetzt
[Musik]
zwei die bahn ist ein krankes will ich
selbst hat dazu irgendwie schon gesagt
dass das dass er keinen menschen hast
keine ahnung was also wir wollen ja auch
willi wills wissen den video überhaupt
nicht irgendwie beleidigen oder keine
ahnung was ist dem gdw dividende
lediglich zur unterhaltung richtig auf
jeden fall hat wie die selber dazu
gesagt dass das alles irgendwie sachen
sind die aus dem kontext gerissen wurden
und ihr müsst ihr euch hat auch
überlegen willi spricht in seiner
sendung die da natürlich irgendwie auf
ki.ka läuft oder morgens auf zdf de
spricht der kleine kinder an
und gerade wenn es dann irgendwie um die
jobs gingen sagt er da gemacht da saßen
kinder im rollstuhl und er ist
aufgestellt beide guck mal ich kann
laufen das ist halt um den kindern die
das gucken hat die unterschiede zu
zeigen was alles an moderation oder oder
überleitungen wir wollen bin ich immer
ein bisschen in schutz nehmen der typ
ist kein schlechter mensch und was
manuellsen oder so beispielsweise die
den beleidigt haben
die auf youtube das gehört sich nicht
sie ließen ihren mann
er war meine kindheit
auch wenn ich meinen namen gefragt habe
ob ich schon vorher ein muffin essen
darf nie für jeden gast eines geburtstag
waren zwei muffins geplant weil nämlich
noch ausländern oder sie die länder
[Musik]
das bist du was wenn jemand dein witz
lauter wiederholt und alle anfangen zu
machen ich alle lorbeeren gar nicht so
zu sagen ich bin einfach im moment passt
muss das auf mich wirken lassen und eine
konsequenz mit sicherheit noch geben
habe ich auch mal sowas immer wenn ich
nur gut gegessen habe oder müsli
immerhin die spiele oder auch immer so
das messer was man so halb über die
spüle gelegt hatte man nicht wusste ob
man sich noch ein brot schmiert oder
nicht ob wir sie noch ein sandwich
machst du das nicht weiß zwar zu sauber
für die spülmaschine aber zu dreckig für
und wider
im gerichtssaal grinste er dann nur noch
und äußerte sich zu keinem zeitpunkt die
anfrage per internet störungen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
das
was ist das ich freue mich an erster
stelle
mit
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
junge ist echt so es ist nicht so dass
war sondern der beste freude die beste
freude über den ausgewählten jaja als
die 34 zitronen und kann zugleich
sondern wie zäher einiger
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ja liebe hassen diesen trick einfach
tasche weg geschickt
[Musik]
auf der rüstung nummer eins ist willi
will's wissen wo mein gott oh mein gott
worte können nicht beschreiben was für
ein
es war nicht so schlimm alltag ja wie
ist ein richtiger ehrenmann alter und
jetzt werden einfach aussagen von ihm
aus dem aus dem kontext gerissen und
alle beleidigen den jetzt egal wie
willst du das eine sehr manuellsen kann
ich nicht verstehen alter das ist
einfach das ist einfach so der muss zeit
den kindern beibringen und dann also
lieber hier setzt sich als unicef patin
für die rechte von kindern ein weiteres
botschafter von trauerland zentrum für
trauernde kinder und jugendliche in
bremens nehme man es in ihrem mann
sozusagen damit mehr raum ein gutes ende
wenn euch der heutige nicht anständig
gefallen hat dann das kann einen daumen
hoch unter dem video da meine lieben
freunde und jetzt mal ein kanal falls
doch keinen dialog schon seit oder
klickt hier auf den smiley drauf was
anderes gesicht dann werdet ihr nicht
kostenlos aber nicht von meinem kanal
verpasst keine videos mehr und hier ist
ein anderes video verlinkt die letzte
nicht an den challenge mit sandra die
könnt ihr euch da anschauen auch wieder
sehr sehr sehr sehr witzig soeben ist
der neue podcast folge online gegangen
spotify punkt kommen schriftlich und
doof dieses t shirt die lounge am 20
um 15 uhr lukas heins das werbevideo